bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors on vient de parler
des objectifs de cette visite un
réclamer le retour des civils au pouvoir
et demander un calendrier électoral
clair sur ce point précis que 10 pour le
moment les militaires puisqu'on sait que
la cedeao a proposé une date le 27
février 2000 22 pour des élections
il vu la situation actuelle le
gouvernement malien estime que la
priorité absolue aux urgences j'espère
que ce n'est pas l'organisation des
élections dans des conditions actuelles
de la situation sécuritaire et politique
du mali je ne vois pas comment
aujourd'hui le mali soit capable
d'organiser en deux mois presque deux
mois une élection présidentielle alors
que beaucoup beaucoup de contraintes ce
qui les terres et politiques non à la
non application de l'accord d'alger la
stabilité politique du pays font
qu'aujourd'hui il est pratiquement
impossible même si la paix siens et
porte du côté de la cedeao ou de l'onu
sur ce gouvernement qu'il faut donc
assurer la stabilité politique selon
vous avant d'organiser des élections
mais si le mali n'organise pas des
scellés des élections à la date prévue
par la cedeao il y aurait une vraie
perte de crédibilité de la part de
l'institution
justement cette délégation de l'onu le
rôle de cette délégation vu sa
composition et le cadre dans lequel
s'est déplacée on va très bien aussi que
ce n'est pas seulement pour mettre la
pression sur le gouvernement malien
n'est plus tôt c'est aussi pour faire un
arbitrage entre la cedeao le
gouvernement alliant est aussi le
partenaire impliqué dans la crise
malienne tels que la france avec qui le
mari avait conscience moment de cette
délégation est aussi pour apaiser la
situation écoutez évaluer la situation
politique ce n'est pas seulement pour
venir imposer des conditions clairement
au gouvernement c'est pour venir
dialoguer pourparlers avec la jeune
évaluer la situation et peut-être après
c'est d'en tirer les conclusions sur les
yeux ou les pressions à m où l'exigence
à m gouvernement en matière des
élections le gouvernement malien à
travers l'économie nationale maga
expliqué qu'il fallait d'abord une
assise pour que les maliens puissent se
mettre autour d'une table c'est parler
s'est réconcilié faire la paix et aller
aux élections ils ont dit qu'ils
seraient là riac d'organiser des
élections pour organiser des élections
ça ne résout absolument tous les
problèmes donc vaut mieux d'aller vers
la paix apaiser la situation afin de
pouvoir organiser des élections dans des
conditions sécuritaires politiques
favorables qu'ils puissent être des
élections crédibles parce qu'aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas organiser des élections
sur l'ensemble territoire du mali
comment te remettra de pouvoir aller à
des élections c'est ça la question qui
se pose est cette délégation est là pour
justement pousser le mari à appliquer
les accords d'alger afin que la question
du nord du mali puis s'étaient réglées
afin que le mali puisse organiser
d'élections sur l'ensemble du territoire
et qu'est ce qui bloque selon vous en
concrètement pour une application
véritable des accords d'alger
le point d'achoppement principal est le
fait sur le point de la démobilisation
et la réinsertion des ex rebelles c'est
qu'au talent acquis et qu'il met en
cause les rebelles font pas confiance le
gouvernement malien des mains de
rebelles de se désarmer et de venir
discuter après les rebelles disent non
on essaie d amar désarment pas tu as
causé par le taux et le nombre des
rebelles puissent être intégrés la
réalité de leur prise en charge et la
place offert au sein de cette armée à
l'ex rébellion de l'azawad
vous parlais tout à l'heure en détention
entre paris et bamako on sait que le
pouvoir au mali cherche des partenaires
alternatif à paris la crise justement
entre la france et le mali à quel point
jugez vous son ampleur
on n'a plus à ce moment avec la
désescalade quévert la l'augmentation de
la tension nous on est très bien que
après quelques tensions maximum
aujourd'hui les deux camps sont plus
sains vers l'apaisement et l'écoutent et
avec l'intervention de la cedeao les
pays du g5 sahel et la délégation de
l'onu tout montre qu'aujourd'hui on vole
vers l'apaisement et la compréhension
même si le gouvernement malien s'est
plaint de l'attitude de la france et
cherche des alternatives et aussi
affirme son droit à pouvoir avoir des
liens et des partenaires avec d'autres
partis autres que la france l'attention
sont peut-être en train d'être apaisé et
aller vers le dialogue et la
compréhension entre les deux peuples et
les deux pays pardon
karim et jakub koundougou me merci à
vous je rappelle que vous êtes chercheur
associé au groupe afrique de l'ip ce
merci d'avoir et en direct sur rt france